Bishop to C2 and then going for long  castle and very quick FC for yeah that  that was the problem for Yan so he felt  like the need to create some something  yeah this G5 feels uh quite desperate  yeah yes yeah like you know that it  doesn't feel good and let me try to to  gamble somehow so take sticks e for F4  and that's how we are reaching the  current position the P sacrifice just  appeared with ed5 ft G3 rookie one  checking D7 HTC G3 Knight F5 and that's  the current position  yeah but how okay so how do you attack  like  or concretely well I think you are the  one who is a big attacker  let me try to defend it  yeah  no it feels like at some point uh  definitely we should take on C6 yes DTX  C6 played okay I'm believing that btx C6  should be played and D5